how many of you have your end of life
arrangements in order it's a daunting
task that you might still be putting off
but experts say put it on your to-do
list for the year if not for yourself
for your family members
they may have been idolized for their
talent singers like aretha franklin
prince and bob marley but despite their
music fame and fortune they neglected to
take care of a very important detail a
will how can someone at that level who
has so much respect and everything
seemingly together
not have this really basic document in
place even our very own zappos ceo tony
shea responsible for much of the
positive changes we've seen in downtown
las vegas where some 500 million at the
time of his passing last december did
not have his finances in order like many
people famous or not one probably
doesn't want to think about end of life
arrangements but patrick hills with
trust and wills says fear should not
lead to inaction we're trusting well
we've seen this a lot the individuals
they put off having a plan in place
because of fear of what that process
really involves how do i find an
attorney how long will it take how much
is it going to cost how do i take time
off work to go handle these appointments
hicks says when you don't have a plan in
place it's a breeding ground for
problems and confusion so he says start
with something basic that you can tweak
along the way think what's important to
you what would you want to happen to
your kids pets what would you want to
leave to certain family members a plan
even if not the perfect one is a lot
better than not having one at all once
people finally start the process it's
really not that bad most people say at
the end i can't believe this was this
easy i can't believe i put it off for so
long
and remember if you haven't taken care
of this yet you are not alone in 2020
according to research conducted by
caring.com only 32 percent of american
adults said they had a will or other
estate planning document in place